[Música]
[Aplausos]
Ay mamá Antonio
[Música]
a miles de kilómetros de kiev se agita
la bandera rusa en las calles de banji
capital de la República centroafricana
una antigua Colonia francesa
[Música]
un corazón Aquí
los rusos le pidieron a Ucrania que
detuviera sus ataques pero los
ucranianos no obedecieron entonces Rusia
atacó a Ucrania eso es lo que hay que
entender
estas manifestaciones son organizadas
por una asociación anti francesa y
financiadas por los rusos
Rusia está pasando por un momento
difícil y tenemos la obligación de darle
un apoyo moral
esta manifestación es solo para
demostrarle que la República
centroafricana la apoya en todos los
niveles
[Música]
un Aliado ruso indispensable para la
república centroafricana
el país estuvo desgarrado por décadas de
guerra civil y volvió a caer en la
violencia al año pasado amenazado por
Rebeldes que rodeaba en la capital el
gobierno movilizó a todas las fuerzas
que tenía su disposición
ustedes defienden el país defienden la
nación contra los Rebeldes y Los
Mercenarios
no deben ceder ni un centímetro de
nuestro territorio nacional
cuentan con todo nuestro ánimo y nuestro
apoyo
descansen
[Música]
junto al ejército centroafricano había
también hombres blancos con el rostro
siempre cubierto
al Amparo de un acuerdo de defensa con
Moscú miles de combatientes rusos
llegaron a la República centroafricana
Los mercenarios que operaban En nombre
del grupo Wagner eran un ejército
desconocido al Servicio del kremlins sin
existencia legal
[Música]
eran también los escoltas del presidente
de la república faustinar santuadera
Moscú hacía avanzar sus peones por el
continente en detrimento de la
influencia francesa durante las grandes
ceremonias empezaron a alzar las
banderas rusas en tanques regalados por
el kremlin hasta unos músicos de Moscú
celebraron esta Alianza
[Música]
la propaganda se había puesto en marcha
y Rusia entraba en acción un año después
el ejército y sus aliados rusos hicieron
retroceder a los Rebeldes fuera de las
ciudades en banki la vida cotidiana ha
retomado su curso pero Los mercenarios
siguen ahí y pasan más desapercibidos
son casi imperceptibles huyen de las
cámaras la única Universidad del país
los estudiantes vuelven a sus primeras
clases después de la guerra
uno de ellos tres hora de está a punto
de terminar su carrera de derecho
es uno de los defensores más virulentos
de la intervención rusa
[Música]
estabilidad es el fruto del arduo
trabajo de nuestros aliados
cuando hablo de nuestros aliados me
refiero a la fuerza rusa
como ya hay una seguridad una
estabilidad tenemos la esperanza de que
nuestros hermanos menores puedan
estudiar en mejores condiciones
al salir de clase tres or se detiene la
entrada de la universidad
aquí los rusos se erigieron un monumento
en honor a sus combatientes
[Música]
hay una mujer con sus hijos detrás y los
militares están delante eso dice mucho
da una visión general sobre la seguridad
de la población civil
estos militares son las fuerzas armadas
centroafricanas y los rusos Cuando veo
esto veo esperanza
hoy es para una madre para unos niños
mañana será para mí ellos me protegerán
cuando lo miro me siento tranquilo
porque veo seguridad
me siento tranquilo al saber que cuando
me ataquen ellos estarán ahí para
protegerme
Cuando veo Esto me siento contento
agradecido los aplaudo por lo que han
hecho
la esperanza que despertó la llegada de
los rusos en la República centroafricana
está vinculada con el pasado trágico y
sanguinario del país y con sus cinco
millones de habitantes atrapados en una
guerra civil interminable marcada por
las masacres;
bangui todavía carga los estigmas de
esos enfrentamientos en el barrio de
trésor al borde de la carretera
descansan los cuerpos de decenas de
habitantes Víctimas de las milicias en
aquí desde ese extremo de allá hasta
aquí
hay una dos tres cuatro cinco tumbas
es el cementerio de la población civil
asesinada por los Rebeldes cada vez que
vengo aquí me inclino nos Recuerda
siempre a nuestros hermanos y hermanas
que perdieron sus vidas durante esos
eventos tan dolorosos en una época había
lugares donde no se podía cruzar la
calle había sectores que no se podían
pisar porque estaban ocupados por los
Rebeldes entonces personalmente Yo
también viví muchas cosas
con las heridas de 2013 recién curadas
la población seguía temiendo que se
produjera un nuevo desastre ocho años
después los Rebeldes regresaron a las
puertas de la ciudad justo detrás de
estas Colinas
estaban de este lado algunos ya estaban
en la capital disfrazados de población
civil
pero con el apoyo de nuestros aliados
los rusos y los ruandeses los hicimos
retroceder y por ahora el país está en
paz retrocedieron hasta las
profundidades del país Entonces eso nos
da una esperanza de no volver a revivir
el pasado
no revivir el infierno después de
décadas de Caos el país se ha venido
abajo
la economía está al límite y la mayoría
de los centroafricanos no tiene
suficiente para comer
[Aplausos]
en estos barrios de bangie reina el
sentimiento de haber sido abandonados
por Francia antigua potencia
colonizadora un terreno fértil para
sembrar nuevas ideas
financiados por los rusos y por el
gobierno tres horas y sus compañeros
organizan concentraciones para apoyar a
Moscú
la juventud de hoy no es la misma de
ayer estamos cambiando las cosas siempre
rebeldes en el interior del país pero
hoy en tres meses
con lo que Rusia ha hecho aquí la
situación ha mejorado ahora nosotros los
jóvenes debemos tomar las decisiones
discurso pero ruso está bien establecido
y el lenguaje sea perfeccionado ahora
otra bandera tricolor reemplaza la
francesa
si miramos un poco hacia atrás la
historia demuestra que Rusia nunca ha
colonizado un país africano no estamos
en contra de Francia pero fue la mala
política de Francia la que nos hizo daño
Cuántos años estuvimos con Francia Miren
el estado del país Cuántos golpes de
estado hubo Cuántas rebeliones Cuántos
presidentes de la República
centroafricana perdimos hoy con la
presencia rusa en un lapso corto hemos
tenido un buen resultado y eso me ha
llevado a comprometerme y a apoyar a
Rusia
porque lo que queremos es bienestar no
la libre circulación hoy tenemos
seguridad los jóvenes pueden ir a la
escuela nuestros hijos pueden ir a
estudiar y eso lo viendo ahora es algo
que me da valentía y me da ganas de
alzar la bandera para darle gracias a
Rusia al presidente Putin
los discursos prorrusos se mezclan con
los argumentos contra una Francia que ha
perdido influencia
un vacío que Moscú lleno rápidamente la
cerveza local propiedad de un grupo
francés Es la bebida más popular entre
los centroafricanos
pero ahora enfrenta una competencia
Rusia ha extendido su influencia hasta
en los bares de la capital con el primer
vodka comercializado en la República
centroafricana fabricado por una empresa
que también es cercana a Los mercenarios
rusos
[Música]
nave africana technologity a Rush
significa fabricado en RCA con
tecnología rusa es fuerte pero está bien
es demasiado fuerte la energía
[Música]
la operación de seducción ya había
aparecido en la gran pantalla en 2021
en bankie durante una semana miles de
personas asistieron al gran estreno de
turista una película de acción rusa
filmada en la República centroafricana
la película fue producida por una
empresa de la galaxia Wagner y habla
sobre la intervención de Los mercenarios
en el país tiene todos los códigos de un
éxito de taquilla estadounidense excepto
por algunos detalles
[Música]
les decimos
decidimos que nuestra película estaría
basada en hechos reales
en escenas de acción reales sobre lo que
pasa de verdad
Wagner ha tomado todas las medidas para
convertir a la República centroafricana
en una vitrina de su intervención
profesional
[Aplausos]
el objetivo se parece a una vieja
historia conquistar los corazones y las
mentes
[Música]
claro
me vuelvo a ver en mi papel de actor fue
maravilloso
meló un joven actor obtuvo uno de los
roles principales en turista el papel de
una vida en la película de propaganda
interpreta al enemigo de los rusos
si no es un paseo
secreto
una oportunidad única pero peligrosa
para melón interpretar al antiguo
presidente busyé que se volvió un jefe
Rebelde y enemigo público en la
República centroafricana Tiene sus
riesgos
piensan que como interpreté a positivo
no hay fotos mías con ese tipo yo hice
mi trabajo no tengo nada que ver con los
rusos que llegan pero los rusos
necesitan actores buenos actores y yo
hice mi trabajo pero siempre hay alguien
que no lo entiende dirá que estoy a
favor de por sí sé vendrá a matarme
porque cree que soy uno de sus hombres
y familia mi madre todavía está aquí mis
hijos toda mi familia que les voy a
dejar ni siquiera tengo un techo un sofá
no tengo nada
[Música]
en un país sin Industria del cine es
difícil del actor me lo soñaba con una
carrera internacional que pudiera
cambiar su vida y la de su familia
si ven a mi familia donde vivo no hay
nada de una persona que ha actuado en
una gran película
Una película que fue un éxito en la
República centroafricana
normalmente si hubiera sido en otra
parte ya tendría un buen carro estaría
construyendo una casa para mí para ver
sí
Ya ven cómo son las condiciones de
trabajo aquí Cómo es el medio en el que
trabaja
sin embargo hace un año Melo caminaba
por la alfombra roja delante de una
multitud en júbilo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoy los afiches sean de Colorado las
gradas están vacías y Melo se siente
Atrapado en un conflicto que lo supera
[Música]
es la guerra de los medios la guerra de
la comunicación cada uno trata de que su
ejército sea lo más grande posible
este conflicto tiene muchos ángulos
pero los rusos son solo una pequeña
parte
han participado en lo que los concierne
pero te bajo hay mucho más
[Música]
lo que no aparece en la película y que
la propaganda evita cuidadosamente de
mencionar son las víctimas de Los
Mercenarios
torturas violaciones asesinatos saqueos
y otros crímenes de guerra
las Naciones Unidas han acusado a los
rusos de una centena de exacciones
asociaciones locales como la de aliusman
discretamente recogen testimonios en el
barrio musulmán de Bambi
Leila tiene 25 años es la viuda de un
comerciante de oro y diamantes en el
centro del país su esposo fue asesinado
por una patrulla militar dirigida por
los rusos
estaba viajando entre las minas de oro y
diamantes para revenderlos en la ciudad
de banbary
un día me enteré de que unos militares
estaban haciendo una operación en esa
ruta
Pero él quiso correr el riesgo
no tenía nada que esconder y quería
reunirse conmigo y con los niños
los militares lo detuvieron
le robaron los diamantes el oro y los
regalos para los niños
primero trataron de matarlo con un fusil
pero el arma hace en casquilló
Entonces lo ataron antes de apuñalarlo
con un cuchillo
Los mercenarios rusos se han adueñado de
las minas para revender el oro y los
diamantes
están enfrascados en una lucha perpetua
con Los Rebeldes cuyas finanzas también
dependen de la venta de minerales
las poblaciones no están a salvo
[Música]
las personas están atrapadas en un fuego
cruzado unos y otros cometen exacciones
y abusos contra la población civil son
casos que prácticamente se han vuelto
banales casi nadie se conmueve no está
cerca de terminar solo se acentúa
existen miles de historias como la de
Leyla la mayoría silenciadas por temor a
la represalias
las comunidades musulmanas y fulani son
los blancos más frecuentes en el
interior del país
[Música]
Los mercenarios los asocian a los
Rebeldes miles de ellos han huido de la
violencia y la persecución
la mayoría se instalan en este barrio
temiéndole a los rusos
en el terreno no hemos visto a la Rusia
oficial
es la Rusia informal a través de una
empresa militar que es water si en ese
momento hubieran expulsado Los Rebeldes
pero no los liberaron y es contra de
nosotros que se cometen todas sus
exacciones son personas sin ley ni fe y
eso es lo que estamos renunciando
[Música]
es uno de los pocos en atreverse a
hablar con el rostro descubierto cuando
llegaron los rusos las voces
discordantes fueron silenciadas
la contradicción no se tolera sobre todo
en el barrio del presidente donde desde
temprana edad los niños aprenden a
alabar a Los Mercenarios
[Música]
el autor de Esta canción es un poderoso
ministro el consejero especial del
presidente de la república
es político a otro nivel educativo para
los jóvenes
es referencia a las personas a las que
les gusta proteger a los más débiles
deben recordarlo
[Música]
poco importan las múltiples
investigaciones internacionales que
documentan las masacres de civiles y
señalan la responsabilidad de Los
mercenarios rusos
niña no se respetan los derechos humanos
se destruyen de manera brutal y hasta
salvaje
es proporcional a lo que hacen los
Rebeldes que queman las casas que roban
el ganado
Aquí no hay prisioneros hay que acabar
con ellos porque tienen armas
Moscú ha negado durante mucho tiempo la
existencia de Wagner en Rusia las
actividades mercenarias son ilegales
pero hoy por primera vez el gobierno
centroafricano reconoce su presencia y
Wagner sale de las sombras
[Música]
nos damos un trato con la federación
rusa
sí Putin presidente y jefe comandante
supremo de las fuerzas armadas rusas
no es nuestro problema
para nosotros son rusos hablan ruso
vienen para ayudarnos en el marco de
esta cooperación
da igual que sean rusos Beethoven o
Mozart están aquí para defender la
democracia centroafricana y los
aceptamos
nos encantaría recibir a la legión
extranjera francesa
a Los mercenarios franceses o a Los
mercenarios estadounidenses como en Irak
para que vengan a apoyarnos no tenemos
problema
no vamos a escoger el color del agua
para apagar el fuego en nuestro país
los rusos nos enviaron estas fuerzas que
ustedes llaman wagners
para nosotros no hay problema y no me da
vergüenza usar esta camiseta Ni esta
insignia
la ayuda de Los mercenarios se aceptó
pero no es gratuita
josef bendunga es uno de los pocos
parlamentarios que denuncian el control
que tienen los rusos sobre los recursos
del país
los rusos vinieron porque fueron ellos
los que salvaron el poder en tu madera
se impusieron tomaremos y explotaremos
esta mina
y lo hicieron a sabiendas de todo el
mundo
hoy quien controla esas explotaciones
mineras llevadas por los rusos nadie no
le rinden cuentas a nadie que se llevan
las riquezas de la República
centroafricana lo que la comunidad
internacional actualmente está haciendo
por Ucrania
debería hacerlo por la República
centroafricana los rusos fueron a atacar
Ucrania
a destruir a saquear
y es lo mismo que están haciendo en la
República centroafricana
este eterno militante de la oposición ha
sido encarcelado varias veces a lo largo
de su vida pero no se da por vencido
los centroafricanos Son muy inteligentes
y aunque ahora aceptan todo
cuando empiecen a analizarlo ya verán
que van a encontrar el equilibrio entre
las cosas y tomarán decisiones en
beneficios de sus intereses cuando
llegue ese momento creo que los rusos
sabrán que ya no son Bienvenidos en la
República centroafricana
[Música]
entretanto Los mercenarios rusos siguen
cada vez más presentes en el corazón del
poder para defender a los gobiernos que
sirven sus intereses
[Música]
el modelo seduce a los regímenes
autoritarios en África y Wagner extiende
su influencia
[Música]